bonjour et bienvenue sur la
chaîne de fronde dans ces cartes faites éclater un ballon
eh bien découvrons que les
gens peuvent évidemment souvent penser que
le youtuber est comme une rock star vous
savez juste profiter de la vie toute la journée et
peut-être ensuite investir 30 minutes par jour
pour faire  une vidéo cool si ce n'est pas
le cas c'est un travail très dur ce n'est pas des
vacances c'est des heures supplémentaires vous travaillez le
week-end et vous ne serez jamais aussi célèbre
que je le dis comme une star de la télévision ou une star d'Hollywood
vous prenez le crayon et glissez-
les juste  comme ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
Daniel pour faire la rente Veuve
Ahava papa illustration nom et après
ça a complètement changé je veux dire que mon
revenu d'essence est descendu à environ 20
pour cent de ce qui était avant 1500
euros parfois même moins de
mille  euros et il a également admis que
je devais trouver d'autres sources de revenus, donc j'ai
fait beaucoup de vidéos sponsorisées, le problème est
que le public n'aime pas beaucoup cela,
ils appellent cela une vente et donc
généralement ce qui se passe est le  n vous perdez
vous perdez le public vous connaissez des gens
qui s'enfuient donc ce n'est rien que
vous puissiez faire comme source de revenu durable
[Musique]
c'est comme la situation exacte que nous
avions au début de l'
industrialisation en Europe où un
les propriétaires d'usines sont très puissants et les
travailleurs étaient impuissants et donc
ils ont été très exploités et maltraités
et je pense que la même chose se
reproduit dans la foule qui travaille, etc. et
donc je pense que la solution doit être
la même encore nous devons nous syndiquer nous
avons  être solidaires parce que ce n'est
qu'ensemble que nous sommes forts en tant qu'individus, nous sommes
complètement faibles, donc nous voulons fondamentalement
trois choses différentes premièrement la
transparence nous voulons que YouTube nous dise
tout ce qu'ils savent sur nous et
tout ce qu'ils font à nos vidéos et à
nos presses deuxième chose que nous exigeons
est la communication, nous voulons parler à une vraie personne,
nous voulons quelqu'un qui nous dise
ce qu'il n'aime pas dans une vidéo afin
que nous puissions la changer et gagner de l'argent
avec  h encore une fois et la troisième chose est que nous
voulons l'équité nous voulons que nous voulons être
traités de la même manière
que YouTube traite les grands réseaux
[Musique]
n'abandonnez pas l'éducation ne quittez pas l'
école ne sautez pas vos idées pour aller à
collège ou université parce que vous pensez que
vous pouvez être un youtubeur c'est dangereux
parce que même si vous avez du succès au
départ, il peut toujours arriver que
YouTube supprime votre chaîne et vous
ne pouvez rien y faire
vous